à
le tableau que vous avez sous vos yeux
est un tableau d'arthur grimaud qui est
un peintre qui a qui est né à saint
louis qui est mort à saint paul c'est un
des grands peintres réunionnais du 19e
siècle et il représente en fait une
branche de goyave
qu'il avait peinte en fait ce tableau
avait été peint pour env le directeur du
muséum nature et de l'époque s'appelait
nicolas brayons et il faisait partie
d'un groupe d'une quarantaine de
peintures où il y avait tous les fruits
de la réunion qu'ils avaient tous été
représentés de la même façon on a ici
l'idée d'une planches botaniques c'était
assez de la peinture mais en même temps
cette peinture est là il s'inspire des
documents scientifiques comme les
planches botaniques justement on est là
pour montrer la branche la feuille le
fruit le fruit vert le fruit en train de
mûrir et le fruit mûr et l'intérieur du
fruit que l'on peut voir ici posée sur
le bas du tableau donc c'est un tableau
qui est un tableau à vocation
scientifique mais également à vocation
pictural et décoratives dans la mesure
où il est parti de cette grande commande
qui avaient été faites par nicolas
brayons ce type de représentations
appartient à un jean en fait en peinture
qu'on appelle la nature morte c'est à
dire qu'il n'y a pas de représentation
de personnages il n'y a pas de
représentations de scènes il n'a pas de
représentation de sa liste au rique de
cette religieuse de scènes mythologiques
ce n'est pas un portrait est donc ça
appartient aux gens de natures mortes et
on l'a effectivement regroupés dans
cette partie du musée avec d'autres
peintures de nature morte pour justement
évoqué c'est les 5 gens de la peinture
là tout blanc tout le 19e siècle en fait
la peinture à être organisée en 5 jan le
premier c'était la grande peinture la
peinture d'histoire le deuxième c'était
le portrait le troisième c'était les
scènes anecdotique les scènes de
peinture anecdotique représentants des
petites scènes des paysages et le
quatrième gens c'est le paysage et en
femme le 5e jean c'était la nature mans
c'est aussi pour les peintres comme si
en général très peu souvent le cas des
oeuvres de commande c'est aussi pour les
peintres faire une nature mans c'est
l'occasion de peindre de s'exprimer de
perfectionner son art de perfectionner
sa technique de perfectionner son sens
sa touche et c'est en peignant justement
des natures mortes des fruits des objets
des bouquets de fleurs et des tablettes